Wing went to Singapore to visit his Uncle Lee.
Singapore was hot.
Wing did not like to be hot.
Uncle Lee liked to fish when it was hot.
He took Wing to Bedok Jetty to fish.
Wing had never fished.
"I don't like fishing," said Wing.
"How do you know if you have never tried?" asked Uncle Lee.
"I just know," said Wing.
"Will you try?" asked Uncle Lee.
"Can you teach me?" asked Wing.
"Yes," said Uncle Lee.
Uncle Lee gave Wing a fishing pole.
He showed Wing how to put a worm on the hook.
Uncle Lee threw his line into the water.
Wing threw his line into the water, too.
Uncle Lee felt something pull on his line.
Wing looked to see what it was.
Uncle Lee had caught a fish.
Wing wanted to catch a fish.
Uncle Lee had caught five fish.
Wing had not caught any.
"I don't like fishing," said Wing.
"You will catch a fish," said Uncle Lee.
Wing felt something pull on his line.
He looked to see what it was.
He did not see a fish.
Wing pulled his line out of the water.
The worm was gone!
Uncle Lee and Wing laughed together.
"I want to try again," said Wing.
Uncle Lee put a worm on Wing's hook.
Wing threw his line into the water.
He felt something pull on his line.
Uncle Lee looked to see what it was.
Wing had caught a fish.
Wing had caught a big fish.
"I like fishing in Singapore," said Wing.